[Musique]
rien n'est plus logique
si tenté que la logique conduisent le
monde
rien n'est plus logique aujourd'hui que
de constituer un marché commun européen
il y à des pays qui sont voisins entre
eux la france l'allemagne l'italie la
hollande la belgique le luxembourg un
jour probablement l'angleterre un jour
aussi
l'espagne peut être d'autres voilà un
fait géographique qui est devenu aussi
un fait économique
parce qu'ils sont très rapprochés
parce que ils sont en contact immédiat
lé direct les uns avec les autres et
puis parce qu'ils sont du même ordre
économique
les uns et les autres ils sont hommes
étiage
dans leur ensemble
enfin parce que aujourd'hui
la concurrence
est nécessaire c'est l'aiguillon qui est
indispensable au progrès et notamment
aux progrès économique
qui serait absurde pour un pays de
s'enfermer comme on le faisait autrefois
comme nous le faisions autrefois dans
des douanes et dans les barrières
et que par conséquent pour se mettre à
la page jour après jour année après
année il faut encore une fois la
concurrence bref il vaut un marché
étendu
c'est pourquoi
je suis tout à fait convaincu et je
crois même si comme tout le monde
qu'il est bon qu'il est utile et même
qu'il est nécessaire d'aboutir à créer
un marché commun entre les six
c'est pas moi qui ai fait le traité de
rome
qui comme vous le savez a institué en
principe ce marché commun
une preuve que si j'avais été aux
affaires quand on a fait le traité de
rome ont leurs effets d'une manière
assez différente
mais enfin je les prie commune était et
avec mon gouvernement nous avons tâché
d'en tirer le meilleur parti possible
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire
ça voulait dire au point de vue
industriel
que progressivement et à mesure que
notre industrie à nous se mettent à la
hauteur des industries concurrentes en
particulier l'industrie allemand eh bien
on pouvait ouvrir devait ouvrir les
barrières douanières et communiquer
largement
entre soi
il fallait bien entendu des règles à
toutes sortes d'écart et je conviens que
le traité de rome
prévoit ces règles pour l'industrie
d'une manière raisonnable et puis à
l'agriculture un pays comme le nôtre ne
veut pas se lancer dans la concurrence
économique du moment qu'elle ne serait
qu'un industriel
parce que si nous restions avec sur les
bras le poids de notre agriculture qui
est très lourd j'ai parlé hier de la
transformation agricole et duke ce que
l'état doit faire pour cette
transformation
si nous restions seule parmi les six par
exemple avec la charge exclusive de
notre agriculture
nous serions handicapés dans la
concurrence industrielle et pour nous le
marché commun deviendrait du prix
mais il faut bien convenir que le traité
de rome ne parler que très vaguement de
ceux qui étaient agricole
il parlait très largement d'une manière
très explicite de ce qui était
industriels mais je le répète très
vaguement de ce qu'était agricole soit
parce que l'école dirigeants d'alors se
souciait dans les relations
internationales et les conventions
internationales
de faire beaucoup plaisir aux autres et
les autres c'était des puissances
industrielles
avant tout l'industrie allemande soit
parce que le problème de l'encré de
l'agriculture française dans le marché
commun était un problème et n'a eu que
on reculait devant cette nécessité et
ben depuis que moi même et mon
gouvernement nous avons pris en main
l'application du traité de rome la mise
en oeuvre du traité de rome nous nous
sommes acharnés à faire entrer
l'agriculture française dans le marché
commun et ce n'est pas commode pourquoi
parce que je vous le répète nous sommes
à cet égard un pays très particulier
nous avons une agriculture très
considérable à tous les égards ce qui
n'est pas le cas des autres
un pays comme l'allemagne comment se
nourrit-il il se nourrit à peine pour la
moitié de ce qui produit et le reste il
importe et puis nous ce n'est pas le cas
nos agriculteurs font du blé plus que
nous ne mangeons ils font de la viande
et il devrait en faire plus que nous
pouvons en manger et le peuvent il faut
du lait plus que l'on buvait il faut du
vin plus que sorbon il faut du fromage
plus que nous n'arrivons à le manger sur
nos tables tout ça doit être exportée
exporter ou exportés dans le marché
commun pensez bien que ce n'est pas sans
mal qu'on pouvait réaliser cela c'est à
quoi je le répète nous sommes appliqués
à ce point que le 1er janvier 1963 et
les jours qui suivirent est venu
l'échéance ou bien l'agriculture
française entre dans le marché commun et
les autres acceptent ou bien est-ce que
nous n'allons pas arrêter le marché
commun et nous avons mis ce c'est le cas
de le dire ce marché à la main de nos
partenaires et ils ont consenti ce jour
là ces jours là à faire entrer
l'agriculture française dans le marché
comme
mais il suffisait pas de le dire
sallèles faire et c'était pas commode la
preuve c'est qu'à la dernière échéance
c'est-à-dire le 30 juin dernier où il
fallait effectivement abouti avec le
règlement financier on n'a pas pu
aboutir nous avons trouvé encore toutes
sortes de réticence devant nous et il
n'y a pas moyen d'aller plus loin
alors que faire eh bien il faudra
prendre à la question et comme vous le
savez comme nous l'avons dit nous y
sommes pour nous pour notre part nous
français tout disposés et même réseau à
condition bien entendu que ce soit pour
aboutir et qu'on ne vienne pas à d'orner
si je peux dire
cette entrée de l'agriculture française
dans le marché commun qui complétera
l'ensemble économique des six qu'on
n'aille pas à d'orner cela deux
conditions politiques dont nous aurons
et a parlé tout à l'heure et qui au
point de vue de la france évidemment ne
sont pas acceptables voilà où en sont
les choses voilà la route qui est
ouverte et voilà les espoirs que nous
avons en général je crois que le marché
commun ça nous amène presque
automatiquement à l'europe et là encore
si je disais tout à l'heure on vous a
accusé d'être contre le marché commun de
ne pas y croire de ne pas le vouloir on
vous accuse aussi très fréquemment de ne
pas être européens et de ne pas croire à
l'europe et pourtant vous avez parlé un
jour ou tout au moins on a essayé de
définir votre conception de l'europe en
disant l'europe des patries vous avez
souvent parlé de l'europe de
l'atlantique à l'oural seulement
l'europe des patries j'ai l'impression
que ceux qui se croient qu'ils se disent
européen trouve que ce n'est pas assez
et l'europe de l'atlantique à l'oural
ils trouvent que c'est trop alors je
vous pose très nettement la question mon
général est ce que vous êtes européens
ou non
du mouvement je suis français je suis
européen étant donné que nous sommes en
europe et que je dirais même que la
france a toujours été une partie
essentielle sinon capitale de l'eure par
conséquent bien sûr que je suis européen
alors on me demandait si je suis pour
une organisation de l'europe et si je
vous entends bien vous voulez parler
d'une organisation de l'europe
occidentale
à cet égard je ne sais pas si vous
arrive de relire des déclarations que
j'ai pu faire depuis des années les
années si cela vous arrive vous vous
apercevrez que j'ai parlé de l'europe et
en particulier de la conjonction de
lagnes groupement de l'europe
occidentale avant que personne n'en pas
et même en pleine guerre parce que je
crois que c'est en effet indispensable
je crois qu'il y a dès lors que nous
nous battons plus entre européens et
occidentaux
dès lors qu'il ya plus de rivalité
immédiate et capa de guerre ni mais
denis même de guerre imaginables entre
la france et l'allemagne entre la france
et l'italie même bien entendu un jour
entre la france l'allemagne l'italie et
l'angleterre eh bien il est absolument
normal que s'établisse entre ces pays
occidentaux une solidarité c'est cela
l'europe et je crois que cette
solidarité doit être organisé il s'agit
de savoir comment et sous quelle forme
alors il faut prendre les choses comme
elles sont car en fait pas de politique
autrement que sur des réalités bien
entendu on peut sauter sur sa chaise
comme un cabri en disant l'europe
l'europe l'europe mais ça n'aboutit à
rien et ça ne signifie rien je répète il
faut prendre les choses comme elles sont
comment sont-elles vous avez un pays
français deux points discutés et alain
vous avez un pays allemand pour discuter
en un vous avez un pays qu à rien vous
avez un pays belge l'olympie hollandais
vous avez un pays luxembourgeois et vous
avez un peu plus loin un pays anglais et
vous avez un pays espagnol et cetera ce
sont des pays ils ont leur histoire ils
ont leur langue ils ont leur manière de
vivre et ils sont des français des
allemands des italiens des anglais des
hollandais des belges espagnols les
luxembourgeois ce sont ces pays là qu'il
faut mettre ensemble et ce sont ces pays
là qu'il faut habituer progressivement à
vivre ensemble et à agir en ce sens à
cet égard je suis le premier à
reconnaître et à penser que le marché
commun et s entière car si on arrive à
l'organiser et par conséquent à établir
une réelle solidarité économique entre
ces pays européens on aura fait beaucoup
pour leur rapprochement fondamentale et
pour leur vie commune alors ya le
domaine politique que peuvent-ils faire
en commun politiquement
il y a deux choses à considérer
quand on parle de politique
le tout temps et notamment par le temps
qui courent il ya à considérer la
défense dans le cas où on serait obligé
de se défend et pia considérer l'action
c'est à dire ce que l'on fait au dehors
au point de vue de la défense
sur cette europe occidentale devait être
attaqué et par qui pourraient l'être
jusqu'à présent au plus tôt jusqu'à ces
derniers temps on pourrait imaginer
qu'elle risquait de lettres partir de
l'est et ce n'est pas encore absolument
impossible dans ce cas là il y à une
solidarité de défense entre les six et
cette solidarité je le crois peut et
doit être organisé et puis à l'action
c'est à dire ce que cet ensemble devrait
faire dans le monde alors à cet égard là
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
car il faut bien convenir que les uns et
les autres ne font pas tous la même
chose et ne voient pas tous les choses
de la même façon les allemands que
voulez vous il se voit comme ils sont
c'est à dire coupé en deux et même trois
si l'on tient compte du statut de berlin
et il se retrouve avec une puissance
économique rené santé qui est déjà
considérable forcément ils ont des
ambitions est il nécessaire
que les ambitions de l'allemagne soit
automatiquement les nôtres les anglais
ont à faire un peu partout et on le voit
bien il en disant barras actuellement en
afrique avec l'ardesi ils en ont dans
les pays arabes l'avaient cadène ils en
ont en extrême orient avec la malaisie
et ainsi de suite est ce que ces ennuis
ces inconvénients doivent être
nécessairement les nôtres en même temps
voyez-vous ce que je veux dire il est
pas si facile que ça d'ajuster les
politiques
alors
j'ai fait peut-être vous en souvenez
vous c'était en 1961 la première de
toutes les propositions qui était faite
aux européens pour commencer une
coopération politique je leur ai proposé
de réunir périodiquement en sang les
chefs d'état et gouvernement
et puis les différentes sortes de venice
notamment emile affaires étrangères pour
confronter la situation de chacun et vue
de chacun et les accords d oui c'est ce
qu'on avait à régler bien que vous
n'ayez pas je prends prononcé la formule
est ce qu'on avait appellé l'europe des
patries à ce moment je n'ai jamais parlé
d'europe des patins c'est comme la
tendance
chacun à sa patrie nous avons la nôtre
les allemands la leur les anglais en a
l'air et c'est ainsi j'ai parlé de la
coopération des états alors ça oui nous
en ait parlé et je crois que c'est
indispensable et nous avons tâché de
l'organiser à cette époque mais ça n'a
pas réussi et depuis on n'a plus rien
fait et que c'est nous qui avons fait
quelque chose avec l'allemagne car nous
avons solennellement c'était incroyable
a pas tout ce qui nous était arrivé nous
avons solennellement fait avec
l'allemagne un traité de réconciliation
et de coopération
ça n'a pas non plus jusqu'à présent
donné grand chose parce que parce que
les politiques sont les politiques des
états et qu'on ne peut pas empêcher ça
alors avait ni crime elle rappelé
supranationale km tous ensemble yaka
fondent tous ensemble français des
allemands les italiens les anglais et
cetera oui vous savez c'est commode et
quelquefois c'est assez séduisant on va
ce régime est rendra sur des mythes
mais ce ne sont que les chimères débite
il y a les réalités et les réalités se
traite pas comme ça les réalités se
traite à partir d'elle-même et c'est ce
que nous nous efforçons de faire et
c'est ce que nous nous proposons de
continuer de faire si nous arrivons à
surmonter l'épreuve du marché commun
j'espère bien que nous le ferons il
faudra reprendre ce que la france a
proposé en 62 et qui n'avait pas réussi
à 61 et qui n'avait pas réussi du
premier coup
c'est à dire l'organisation
d'une coopération politique naissante
entre les états de l'europe occidentale
et à ce moment là il est fort probable
un peu plus tôt un peu plus tard
l'angleterre via besoin et ce serait une
naturelle bien entendu se replacera pas
comme il dit supra nationale elle sera
comme elle est elle commencera par être
une coopération peut-être qu'après à
force de vivre ensemble elle deviendra
une confédération
eh bien je n'envisage eux très
volontiers ce n'est pas du tout
impossible
mon général je voudrais maintenant vous
posez eu un certain nombre d'autres
questions je me permets de vous de vous
rappeler parce que tout en vous écoutant
j'ai l'oeil sur le chronomètre excusez
moi que nous avons encore à peu près 12
minutes je voudrais vous poser la
question suivante on dit aussi très
fréquemment que vous êtes anti américain
vous avez une fois parler d'hégémonie
américaine les américains ont mal pris
cela ils ont considéré que c'était
péjoratif et même beaucoup de français
considèrent que c'est péjoratif alors
est ce que vous pourriez également là
dessus vous expliquer sur votre anti
américanisme vous savez depuis que j'ai
eu à faire une action nationale c'est à
dire depuis
1940 qui était en même temps et l'action
internationale je me suis toujours
entendu traiter d'anti quelque chose je
me rappelle avec ce pauvre churchill il
me disait vous garantit britannique
c'était assez drôle puisque j'étais
actuellement avec ce dimanche au ray
nous étions les seuls français qui
soyons restés à combattre aux côtés de
l'angleterre les américains après on dit
vous êtes anti américain et alors ils
sont présentés en afrique du nord sans
vouloir que je vienne avec eux à cause
du fait qu'il me considérait comme anti
américain et là les français qui étaient
encore sous l'obédience déficit leur en
tirer dessus par tous les bords en
réalité qui a été l'allié des américains
de bout en bout sinon la france de 2 go
il y en avait pas eu d'autre et le cas
échéant
si le malheur devait arriver ici la
liberté du monde était en cause qui
serait automatiquement les meilleurs
alliés des natures sinon la france et
les états unis comme ils l'ont été
souvent en pareil cas d'ailleurs vous
savez moi je dis pas que les américains
sont anti français et pourtant alors si
c'est parce que nous n'osons pas
toujours accompagné qui serait anti
français eh bien ils nous ont pas
toujours accompagné en 1914 que
voulez-vous nous étions en guerre contre
guillaume ii les américains n'étaient
pas là ils sont arrivés en 1917 ils ont
fort bien fait pour eux et pour tout le
monde en 1940 il n'était pas là et nous
avons été submergés par hitler et ce
n'est qu'en 41 parce que les japonais
ont coulé une partie de la flotte
américaine a peur l'amour que les états
unis sont entrés dans la guerre loin de
moi l'idée de me connaître l'immense
services qu'ils ont rendus à eux au
monde et à nous mêmes en entrant dans la
guerre en 1917 et on entend dans la
guerre en 1941 je le sais bien mais
enfin je ne dis pas qu'ils sont anti
français parce qu'ils ne sont pas
accompagnés toujours je suis pas anti
américain parce qu'actuellement je ne
comprennent pas les américains tous et
en particulier par exemple dans la
politique qu'il mène en asie il est tout
à fait vrai que je ne les en approuve
pas alors de là à dire que je suis
américain anti américain je ne peux pas
les en empêcher mais vous voyez le fond
des choses en général je voudrais que
vous répondiez à deux autres questions
maintenant qui touche certaines dépenses
engagées par votre politique et que
beaucoup jugent exagérée à savoir les
dépenses pour la force de frappe et les
dépenses pour l'aide aux pays du
tiers-monde nous avions une armée quand
je suis arrivé c'est l'armée l'algérie
pour dire le mot ça nous coûtait 30 % de
notre budget
actuellement nous avons une qui est en
train de se rénover complètement à bazas
tommy elle nous coûte 21 % de notre
budget et en tentant d'euros diminuent
de parce que de moitié la durée du
service militaire
si nous n'avions pas cette force
atomique qui
l'instrument terrible dont la capacité
de dissuasion même quand elle n'est pas
en chiffres équivalente à celle des
colosses et tout même énorme de
dissuasion et de sauvegarde si nous ne
l'avions pas ça qu'est ce que nous
aurions ou bien nous aurions pas d'armé
du tout c'est d'une conception alors on
parle plus de la france dans la
coopération du monde pour sa défense et
par conséquent pour sa politique ou bien
alors nous aurions une armée comme on
dit conventionnel
alors ce serait l'armé que les avions en
1957 et encore faudrait lui aurait un
armement moderne qu'alors elle n'avait
pas ça nous coûtera encore bien plus
cher que ce que nous sommes en train de
faire maintenant est infiniment moins
efficace du reste les allemands qui ne
peuvent pas qu'ils ne doivent pas se
faire d armes atomiques les allemands
une armée conventionnelle qui leur coûte
relativement plus cher que nous coûte la
nôtre voilà le fait alors on dit les
pays sous développés
c'est bien on parle des dépenses
extraordinaires que nous faisons pour
les pays sous développés ont dit on dit
la france entretient des rois [ __ ] et
elle ne dépense pas l'argent pour elle
la france donne en effet au total
quelque chose comme 2 milliards de
nouveaux francs pour la coopération des
pays se développer voilà ce qu'elle fait
c'est 2 milliards c'est pas de l'argent
perdu à beaucoup prennent d'abord c'est
ainsi que nous gardons avec ces pays d'à
des liens extrêmement étroits au point
de vue culturel ça va de soi puisque ils
parlent tous français
au point de vue
politique même au point de vue
économique c'est certain puisqu'ils sont
à nos grands débouchés de nos
exportations et puis enfin au point de
vue notre standing international
car il est bon qu'un pays comme la
france et des amis et des amis qu'ils
soient des amis particuliers et pourquoi
pas et en effet c'est ce que nous
faisons un pays comme la france ne veut
pas renoncer un rôle d' aide
internationale elle n'a pas le droit ou
alors une saq pas la france et là par
conséquent cet argent que nous donnons
pour l'aide aux pays sous-développés nez
de l'argent perdu aucun point de vue je
considère même que c'est un très bon
placement en général une dernière
question il nous reste encore cinq
minutes 5 minutes et demie vous parlez
très souvent dans vos conférences de
presse dans vos discours dans vos
allocution de l' équilibre du monde que
vous liée à la notion de paix dans le
monde et puis on vous reproche aussi de
sacrifier volontiers nos alliances
traditionnelles au bénéfice de relations
nouvelles avec les pays de l'est comment
est ce que peut se concilier cette
politique de la france qui est la vôtre
avec le rôle que doit jouer la france
dans l'équilibré du monde et pour la
paix du monde nous avons un monde qui
est en train de changer énormément
d'année en année il est plus le même il
apparaît des forces nouvelles ne parle
par exemple de la chine il y en a
d'autres comme la russie soviétique qui
évolue à l'intérieur d'elle-même et face
au dehors il y en a d'autres comme les
états unis qui évolue aussi et qui d'une
puissance essentiellement isolationniste
qu'ils étaient autrefois
devienne une puissance
interventionniste c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire tout ça c'est un changement
capital et à l'allemagne qui se
transforme et non nous ne savons pas
absolument pas où iront ces ambitions
naturellement nous espérons qu'elles
iront dans le bon sens et nous avons des
raisons de l'espérer mais non peut pas
dire qu'on en soit certains par
conséquent nous sommes obligés de
prendre le monde comme il est il agit et
de vivre dans ce monde alors qu'est ce
que ça signifie ça signifie que la
france n'a à s'interdire à elle même
aucune possibilité la france est pour la
paix il lui faut la paix la france pour
renaître vraiment pour se refaire et
pour s'étendre au sens le plus noble du
terme il lui faut la paix par conséquent
la france cherche la paix cultive la
paix est de la paix partout comment en
étant en rapport avec tout le monde il
n'y a aucune espèce de raison pour que
nous excluons d'avoir de bons rapports
avec ceux ci ou avec cela nous sommes
les alliés américains et leurs amis tant
qu'il a l'air ne subsistait quelques
menaces venant de l'est sur l'europe
occidentale
nous sommes également en termes de plus
en plus étroits avec l'europe de l'est
parce qu'elle existe et baisse qui n'a
aucune espèce de raison pour que nous ne
pourrions pas tous ses contacts
pacifique avec elle nous avons pris des
contacts également pacifique est et
trois déjà assez avec la chine nous en
avons avec d'autres réalités du monde
comme l'amérique latine comme l'afrique
bien entendu comme l'inde comme le japon
et pourquoi pas ceux que nous appelons
l'equilibre qui va avec la paix c'est un
commencement de coopération
internationale et c'est cela que la
france cherche à aider et c'est pourquoi
la france n'exclut les rapports ses
rapports avec qui que ce soit elle
cherche être en contact pratique directe
fécond avec tout le monde il l'est
figurez vous je dirais même qu
actuellement dans le monde si vous
ouvrez attention elle est la seule des
américains tout puissants qu'ils sont ne
sont pas en bon terme tout le monde les
anglais non plus pas encore les
allemands je n'en parle pas la russie
soviétique
ce n'est pas certain nous nous sommes ce
pays là c'est conforme au génie de la
france nous n'en sommes plus à la
domination et à vouloir l'établir mais
nous sommes le peuple fait pour établir
et des la coopération internationale
c'est ça notre ambition nationale
d'aujourd'hui et faute de celle là nous
n'aurions aucune mais il nous en faut
une et celle là nous l'avons elle est
pour le bien de l'homme elle et pour
l'avenir de l'humanité il n'y a que la
france qui puisse jouer ce jeu là il n'y
a que la france qui le joue en général
je vous remercie puisque vous avez
accepté de revenir demain devant les
caméras nous parlerons si vous le voulez
bien pour ce troisième et dernier
entretien de la république et des
institutions eh bien nous en parlerons
de la république
[Musique]